This text was voted without the channels of the National Rally.
Specifically,
was the immigration law passed into the assembly through the National Rally.
So yes and no And let's look at what happened on Tuesday night.
Trois-cent-quarante-neuf deputies voted for,
cent-quatre-vingt-six voted against,
38ed and 4 were absent.
Well,
if we remove the votes from the RN,
then... Well,
it all depends on what we do with them.
1st hypothesis if the Rassemblement National had voted against,
the text would have been rejected 2nd hypothesis,
if all the extreme right haded,
it would have reduced the number of ways to reach to have the majority.
..
Because in the National Assembly,
we do not take into account absentees or abstentionists to vote 1 law.
..
In case of abstention of the RN.
The law would then have collected deux-cent-soixante-et-une lanes,
more than half of the lanes expressed.
This theory that Elizabeth Born decided to prove
2 to which many others can be added.
..
One can imagine that certain deputies of the majority who voted against
ored could have voted for it if the Rassemblement National had
not itself voted in favor of the text.